good evening folks we're here to present
the award for best adapted screenplay
and not to get too technical but that's
the screenplay that was the best at
adapting to whatever harsh conditions
and obstacles were thrown in its way
no it's a screenplay adapted from
another source such as a novel play
short story or a TV show
um
agree to disagree okay
once I agree that you're wrong look
let's not fight I mean my God we have
two Academy Awards between us this is
beneath us
did you win an Oscar well not when you
put it like that but you have two
Academy Awards so technically there's
two between us okay can we just I have
one
no you have two no no I have one well
agree to disagree okay can we go on and
give out this award so that more people
can have Oscars like we do listen mate
you can't just go around saying here are
the nominees for best adapted screenplay